live to everywhere we need to go in the
world
so at your call we're ready
okay i'm assuming i don't need to unmute
myself on my computer
[Music]
i do
is it better now no
why don't you start and we'll see what
we get
i'm going to use representative stage
assist
as my
representative status give me a thumbs
up if you can hear me okay
uh it there's an echo
let me let me try this
is that is it better now no it's worse
now
is there someone in the room um with
their computer audio on
i can't shut mine off yeah
john you good yeah everybody else
you've got everything here that is on
does it give you a mute option no jim
doesn't have these calls
true can you can you mute uh
[Music]
tony
all right you are all set on youtube
representative dolan uh did you want to
just
uh give us a quick uh check on make sure
the the reverberation is gone
okay test one two three four no we're
still getting it
is there anybody in the room does uh
representative piamonte is he still is
he there does he have his
i'm here i can't turn off my microphone
can you can you mute him i don't see him
online
on here either as an attendee or
as a panelist all right are you in the
right meeting
oh excuse me representative let me get
the recording started my apologies
test one two three four
still i'm still hearing it me too
it sounds like it's somebody in the room
that has their audio on
i'm on mute
is it anybody not on you
you might need scott to come in and help
us
that's it
representative piemonte can you sign off
oh you are
is there anybody else online in the room
that isn't on i'm online but i'm
i'm muted online but i'm muted
and i'm muted
all right let me just see if i can get
someone down there to take a look
i did i had to unmute that so that we
could
roll and that's done
test one two three
i didn't get an echo that time
i did request that um someone from it
come down
it's not horrible um i don't know if you
want to get started and we'll have
someone come down in a minute
it's up to you folks in the room because
i think it's the worst for you
all right well let me do this chairman's
script and we'll do the pledge
and we'll get that out of the way
i'll talk softly and try to try not to
have it
oh good morning this is the municipal
county government committee
as chair i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of october 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12.
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized in the
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow
[Music]
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general ford
website notice for this meeting
notice complies with house rules and rsa
91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call
271 3600
or email hcs
dot state dot nh
dot u s in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
christina dyer is the staff assisting us
please note that all votes that i've
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll volvo
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
called attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether it's anybody
in the room with you
if you if you're communicating through
zoom or with the telephone
required under the right to know
he's callable thank you mr chairman
representative dolan
here representative
here
representative tripp president
representative guthrie here
representative rosales
[Music]
representative of salad
representative mccry here
melvin and representative
here i'm present at my residence in
brookline i'm the only one in the room
however there are two family members in
other parts of the house
i'm here i'm alone in my office right
now but my husband
will be coming in and out
i'm here in dover new hampshire uh the
cat may walk by although she's been
banned
representative gilman i am present in my
home in exeter and my husband is also
wondering about the house
majority i am here
i'm here representative davis
president alone
representative
i'm here in my home alone
i am here um at my house in
peterborough i'm alone in the room that
i'm in but there are two
family members in other
parts of the house representative
i am here i am currently alone
my husband is in the house
with headphones on he cannot hear any of
the
proceedings thank you representative
i'm here in my apartment in concord
and i am alive
okay how about representative lasalle
mr clark ice
alone in a room
and at home i would ask if you
were asking you mute your telephone if
you have your phone with you
and i'm sorry for the sound issues we're
having we have an i.t
specialist on the way to help
so please uh if you would uh join me
in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states
america and to the republic for which it
stands
one nation indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
okay on our agenda today
we have seven bills to hear
we'll take a lunch break
and we'll go into an executive session
this afternoon
which the public can observe
so first up today we're going to start
with
house bill 79 which is relative to town
health officers
i don't have anybody scheduled
to speak to this bill i do
recognize that i believe it's
representative marsh
is uh has his hand up and i have allowed
him to speak and i
do believe that he is the prime sponsor
of the bill great okay thank you
marsh thank you mr chairman
and thank you members of the committee
can you hear me
we can very good um i'll also note that
uh
i believe someone from dhhs has signed
up to speak although he may not appear
on your list
but for the record i'm representative
william marsh representing seven towns
in southern carroll county
relevant to this bill i've been the
health officer of the town of brookfield
since
2002 and i'm pleased today to offer you
this bill house bill 79
relative to town health officers this
bill began as a request of the new
hampshire health officers association
we worked on it over the summer and i
want to especially thank the town of
tamworth and their selectmen and health
officer becky mason
who hosted a meeting last summer to work
on the bill
my top priority for this legislative
session is strengthening the public
health system in new hampshire
and this bill is a key piece of that
effort
let me walk you through the bill and hit
the highlights
[Music]
i will wait until you're ready
how are you
so you're gonna
my
for those that are observing we uh
please be patient working on some sound
issues
which
another
test one two three
this time okay
so my yeah
yes
okay test one two three is that better
much better thank you so much thank you
thank you for coming
thank you no problem guys sorry to
interrupt representative marsh please
continue
thank you mr chairman and i thank you
for correcting the problem it sounds
much better on my end i will continue
walking you through the bill
section one updates the appointment of
health officers and requires that health
officers provide
contact information to dhhs
section 2 removes the current
requirement that a health officer be a
state resident
this is a request of several towns and
this requirement has been
waived uh several times in the recent
past
section three requires local boards of
health to meet at least once a year and
report to dhhs on their readiness to
address public health threats
draft templates are in development and
it's my understanding that matt callahan
from dhhs will be here to share them
with you today
section 4 allows deputy health officers
to continue to serve when the health
officer position becomes
vacant section 5 allows a single person
to be the health officer for several
towns
section 6 adds training of health
officers by dhhs
background checks and rulemaking most
importantly regarding new hampshire's
readiness for the next pandemic
it's a requirement for the health
officers association
to report to the hhs oversight committee
and the state health assessment and
state health improvement plan advisory
council
section 7 gives health officers the new
duty to communicate with the
commissioner about non-compliance with
quarantine and enforcement orders
it also gives health officers
enforcement authority in the event of a
public health emergency
the same enforcement authority extended
to health officers
by provision 5 of emergency order 65.
i believe these provisions need to be in
statute to enable lifting the current
state of emergency
section 8 allows data sharing between
health officers and dhhs
thereby enabling health officers to
inform local officials
when actions are advisable to protect
the public
in my town this would have been
extremely helpful
when we had a sudden outbreak of kovitz
shortly after the november election
this is necessary to make our public
health system into a true
system where local officials can work
together with state officials
section 9 requires des to provide a copy
of notices closing pools to local health
officers
a request of the littleton health
officer the contact information in
section 1
will allow this to happen without
burdening des
i thank you for consideration i will be
glad to take questions
are there any questions from those on
the committee
if you would like to raise your hand
electronically you can do that
if you're on the phone you can raise
your hand by hitting star six
mr chair looks like the first hand raise
was from representative porter
okay representative please go ahead
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative marsh
for presenting the bill i only have one
question
the bill authorizes the health officer
to
appoint a deputy health officer the bill
also talks about the health office
requiring training but it doesn't
mention whether the
deputy health officer also requires that
training and i'm wondering if that was
your intention uh
thank you uh representative porter i
appreciate that it might be appropriate
for deputy health officers to have
training
we put in a requirement for health
officers to have training which is a new
requirement
we didn't want to overreach certainly
would be reasonable for the deputy
health officers to have that training as
frequently deputy health officers become
health officers
but we figured this was one step at a
time
thank you
representative marsha do you have uh
your testimony in writing that we could
get a hold of i will be glad to email it
to the committee
thank you and next we have
uh representative uh angie poody as her
hand up yes
thank you mr t thank you representative
marsh
my question to you is having these
changes existed have
had these changes existed in the books
would our approach to pandemic covert 19
would be
helpful
the short answer to that is yes the
longer answer is more complicated as you
know i've served on the governor's
economic reopening task force
we had quite some debate over the summer
as to whether health officers should
have enforcement authority or not
and at the beginning of the summer at
least health officers were in the
position where they could persuade
and educate which was really the
appropriate first step
but if enforcement was needed someone
else had to be called in and the initial
idea was to call on the liquor
commission
by the end of the summer it was decided
that the governor needed to give
enforcement authority to health officers
and he did so by emergency order
i believe the process would have been
smoother had we done that from the very
beginning
but uh as fact of the matter i think we
have created our solution as we've gone
along and done a pretty good job here in
the state of new hampshire
thank you next we have a representative
trip and then we'll go to representative
fieldman
thank you mr chair my question is a
follow-up to uh
representative porter's on the deputy
health officer
uh what exactly is the deputy health
officer's uh duties if it's not uh
identical to the health officer
the deputy health officer in towns that
have one i don't have one in my town
uh would be to assist the health officer
in whatever way the health officer
requests just like the the vice chair
helps the chair in your committee
uh i think it may vary greatly between
towns uh how that is divided up
so the uh follow-up please so the
healthy health officer really has no
uh defined duties or responsible
that is correct they do not have
independent authority
well thank you then next up we have
representative gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative marsh for taking my
question
um i was just wondering if um
you see the health officer as an
independent
department without as a department head
without oversight from
anyone but the select board or town
manager
administration uh well the way the law
is established the
health officers are actually appointed
by the commissioner of health and human
services at the recommendation of the
selectmen
so in that sense the the health officer
reports to the commissioner but the
health officer
i won't say works because in some towns
such as my town the health officer is a
volunteer but but the health officer
certainly reports to the selectmen
perhaps not as frequently as they ought
we're trying to
establish that happen more frequently in
as part of the spill by requiring annual
meetings at least
thank you i see uh representative andrew
cootie's hand
up is that it has been lowered or does
she have another question
no sorry that was a mistake i didn't
roll over
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative mark for taking my
question my question
is with uh with regard to the background
check
um i presume there will be some nominal
fee
that the town is going to have to incur
for that background check um and that
i'm just curious if if that's true i
assume that is true
and do you do you recognize any problem
if the um if the
board of selectmen is acting as the
health officer
just two separate questions i apologize
for that uh
i'll answer the second one first i know
of a number of towns where a member of
the board of selectmen
acts as the health officer and i'm not
aware of any problems with that
as far as requiring a background check
is concerned it is my understanding that
there is a nominal fee for that process
to happen
however i do believe that it is
important that if we give
enforcement authority to health officers
that they have a background check
um despite the fact that that was not a
part of the emergency order that was put
in place this summer
thank you are there any other questions
uh do we do we have a a member of dhhs
on the line that would like to speak
i believe we do mr chair and i've
allowed i believe i've allowed that
person to
speak
the member from dhs asked could you just
identify yourself and go ahead and speak
i'm not hearing anything maybe the
person's under you
is it matthew um whoops there we go
you might not be able to hear me there
we go
um i have allowed matthew
um colleen
to speak i'm not sure if that's
representative from dhhs
is matthew uh fellain on the line
okay uh representative marsh are you
still cool
uh yes i did you know who am
dhhs was going to speak for it is my
understanding that matt callahan is the
person from dhhs who's been assigned to
uh come speak to the committee this
morning so i think you have the correct
person and
technical difficulties can you hear me
now can you hear me now
thank you i don't know what the problem
was but i apologize and i'm ready to
present my testimony
can you also um present a
written copy of that to our clerk
yes i believe that's already been
submitted but if not i will make sure
that happens
thank you go right again thank you good
morning chairman dolan
and the members of the mississippi and
county government committee my name is
matthew kaling i'm a program manager at
the dhhs
division of public health services over
the past four years i've managed the
state program for the appointment
training and technical support of local
health officers um
i'm pleased to have the opportunity to
provide this testimony today on bill
house bill 79 dhhs has worked with
representative marsh during the process
of developing the language for this bill
we're supportive of the bill and we
believe the proposed changes will assist
health officers in their charge of
protecting local public health
representative marsh did an excellent
job reviewing that in section one
he talked about many other suggested
changes and the proposed legislation
would affect rsa 128
should be noted that these items apply
to new hampshire towns and not to cities
the bill will require local board of
health to meet once per year to review
public health threats and readiness to
respond to them this provision will
allow the department to better
understand the types of public health
threats and readiness
of new hampshire communities public
health threats can include chemical
disease
sanitary conditions in housing pests or
road infestations
health nuisances in the form of waste
noise or odors and hoarding of
possessions
or animals another provision the bill
requires the health officers and deputy
health officers share the same
appointment officer term and we believe
this allows for more flexibility
for municipalities to find and nominate
them
we also believe that removing the
residency requirement will allow
communities more opportunity with
recruitment and expand the pool of
eligible persons
during the past year covent 19 response
has provided many lessons on how to best
address threats and manage the public
health emergencies at the state and
local level
dhhs has used the best available
information to create a guidance
that has both met public health
standards and allowed flexibility for
both business
and the public sector in an effort to
inform local officials
about coven 19 guidelines dhhs health
officer liaison
program released over 50 private
listserv messages
and directed two dozen training webinars
on the spread prevention
and treatment of the disease as we
continue to work
to reopen the economy the hhs will rely
heavily on local
local health officers to inform
community members of the public
about public health guidance respond to
complaints and pursue compliance in
collaboration with state agencies
as part of the response to the covenant
19 pandemic dhhs identified some areas
for improvement in further collaboration
with local health authorities
some of the gaps identified included the
need to improve communication
clarify local public health readiness
and support basic training for health
officers
in conclusion dhhs acknowledges that the
changes included in the bill
will provide greater flexibility for
local government to nominate health
officers
improve the ability of health officers
to fulfill their duties under specific
state laws
thank you for the opportunity to provide
this testimony about how we can best
support local communities to address
sanitation
and improve public health thank you for
your testimony is there are there any
questions yes i see uh
representative coleben would like to ask
a question
thank you mr chair my mouse was not
cooperating
and thank you matthew how do you say
your last name correctly
okay helene hey helene thank you for
coming and testifying
i just have a quick question you
mentioned that this covers towns not
cities can you tell me why
under rsa 128 the legislature set that
up to apply to
to town specifically not to cities
so that's the reason we don't have the
authority under 128 to cover cities we
obviously collaborate with them very
well but
just doesn't cover that section got it
thanks
i don't see any other questions are
there any members of the public that
would like to ask the question
i do not see any hands raised all right
saying none i'm going to close the
hearing
well i do see a couple of hands have
come up but i'm not sure if they're for
this meeting brian
lockhart
uh mr lockhart would you like to uh make
a comment
uh yes can you hear me yes i can
hi uh brian lockhart i am the health
officer
from the town of salem um i've been here
since
2002 i am also the vice president
of the new hampshire health office
association and i just wanted to support
uh representative marsh and matt uh with
their testimony
uh we worked together on this and we
really
appreciate the support of representative
marsh and we do support this
they went over all the uh the issues uh
but i just wanted to sort of emphasize
a couple of them um right now there are
no training requirements for health
officers and we think
um you know this is kind of starting out
with a basic three hour
uh requirement we think that's a great
step in the right direction to make sure
that we have a
a trained and competent
health officer in new hampshire for each
each town
the communication the disease reporting
i think is also very important and that
was very apparent during this pandemic
the health officers are very involved
with a variety of issues and i know one
of the representatives asked
um would this have helped having these
new requirements and it sure would
um you know we're responsible for
providing information to our residents
we're involved in in trying to deal with
isolation
and quarantine requirements
however health officers are not notified
of any covet positive cases that
information is
is is not shared with the local health
officers so
we get questions we get calls
from businesses asking how do they
respond how do they deal with
uh a positive employee for covid um
we're doing the best we can but i think
the sharing
of that information that disease
reporting would help
uh all of us um to deal with this
pandemic a little better and
you know we're partners with the state
we want to work with them and i think
that would
that would help all of us thank you
[Music]
thank you mr chair my question is
to matthew galhin
uh did i say a last name right
helene right okay helene
um is there something similar existing
for cities that
had provided that platform during the
pandemic
you know as you probably likely know
most of the cities in new hampshire have
independent health departments certainly
manchester and nashua did a very good
job of managing
the tracking of covid cases and
certainly the
all health officers and have done a good
job with the rollout of a vaccine in
their communities
but um due to clarify
the first part of the of this bill um
that covers rsa 128 covers
towns and not cities the second part for
rsa 141
would cover towns and cities allowing
that information
sharing of information and that the
third part um which was
i think rsa 45 for the reporting of
yes 45 for the regulation pools and
bathing places i believe would cover
both towns
and cities so it's a little different
it's different as the
information goes out thank you
are there any other questions for the uh
for those giving testimony mr chief of
mr trump
mr chair uh representative klee has hurt
hand raised and we also have nate graves
from nhma who has his hand raised
representative
uh thank you very much um and
my question may have already been
answered through representative
manjapudi's uh
question um
i'm not quite sure how to word this when
it comes to the
the reporting are we saying
the um dhhs would report to the local
health officer or in this particular
case or the um
the city's department of health and
human services
i guess i'm a little just confused as to
who's reporting
to the health officer
that question is for mr uh caroline
yes it is thank you i'm sorry
great am i unmuted yet yeah you're doing
fine
great okay um so um
just sorry i got distracted for a second
um there are two
um requirements um for assessing uh
threats at the local level in the state
level it's not a reporting requirement
as much as
ability to share information between the
two so um
under um section three town health
officers local secretary of board of
health they are
the local board of health for each town
i'm sorry i'm reading from hp 79
shall meet at least once per year or as
frequently as needed to review public
health issues and concerns and provide
information as requested
to the department of health and human
services on the readiness to address
relevant public health threats so we're
trying to
provide or we'd like to provide
flexibility here so the town can report
as requested by us
information on them and you might be
familiar with uh
you know the the during summer times
there's often um
outbreaks of mosquito-borne illnesses
and that's one information
where we want improved information
sharing
and if there was say an outbreak or
excessive
bed bugs that were moving from dwellings
to the library which happens often or to
schools
we'd like to share that information and
have the town understand how to manage
that
and how to understand the hazards they
have so that's kind of the first element
right
the local level reporting to and sharing
information with the the state level
dhhs so we can better help them
and there's a second part about a
reporting requirement
so this says on hb 79 line 28
this is section six and i believe it's
page three
page two sorry it says beginning um
november 1st 2021 and annually
the new hampshire health officer
association in consultation with dhhs
shall report to the joint legislative
oversight committee on
hhs established under rsa 126
and the state health assessment and
state health improvement plan advisory
council
regarding the readiness of municipal
health officers to respond to potential
public health threats in new hampshire
so as brian lockhart was just saying as
a representative of the health office
association the idea with the
state work with dhhs gather information
from the locals right which is now
flowing up
and be able to report that to
legislature so they understand both the
public health threats and the readiness
of the local health department to be
able to respond to that
okay thank you uh
any uh last questions from the public
let's take one more
if there's one more uh question out
there
uh the last one mr chairs from h graves
at nhma
please go right ahead good morning mr
chair and i
apologize i thought i had signed up
successfully on friday but i guess not
to testify on this
as well as hb 332 and hb
404. um in any case we are in support
of this bill i won't reiterate the
testimony that has already been given
today i think that was excellent
uh we agree with with all of those
points um
the only thing i would add is that
probably the number one health related
pandemic related issue that we've
received
uh questions about at nhma have been
that ability to communicate between the
local health officers and the state
and there was a lot of frustration
especially over the summer about
how that was being done we think this
bill would address
those issues and assist local health
officers
and the state build a stronger
relationship
and have a better free flow of
information that will help everyone
so we can we can get this pandemic under
control as well as any other issues
thank you any questions from mr graves
yes representative gilner
mr chairman thank you mr grace this
might actually be
addressed by mr k helene um
my question was about the um
effective date and 60 days after passage
are we grandfathering in the existing
or current health officers or they all
have to go through
training and background checks after
this bill is passed
i would defer to dhhs on on how they
would be
applying that portion of the law
other questions seeing none i'm going to
close the hearing
on house bill 79
next up is house bill 88 relative to the
city of clermont
police commission i believe we have
uh representative stapleton that would
like to speak
mr chair
yes my name is walter stapleton i am
the third ward representative from
claremont
uh sullivan county uh district five
and i am a co-sponsor of this bill
this bill is which is
hb 88 is a housekeeping bill
and it basically changes one word in the
bill
um to uh from appointing the police
commission
by the council of farmer instead of
the city manager
and um this repairs some historical
complexity relative uh to uh
the town's history in this regard uh
going back to 1947
where the the
the statue
provided for the provided for the
provision of appointment by the city
manager
uh prior to the city's charter and there
were three revisions
over time in 1963 and 1971
in 1973 where various parts of the law
were regarding the city's operation were
avoided or repealed but we still had the
problem
remaining here to um where the city
manager
was um making the decision
on the police commission and
uh it rightfully should be with uh
reside with the city council
now in 192019 um
the city adopted uh the ordinance
it's now ordinance number 570
to rectify this as far as we're
concerned on a local basis
but because it was a matter of statute
to begin with
we needed to have it cleaned up
so we're calling the the ordinance
coincides with
uh correct statute mandate
pence we we strive to
um in bill 88 to change
the appointment of the police commission
from the city manager to the city
council
now the city manager still becomes a
member of the police commission
and is a ex-officio for advice
and guidance and recommendations and so
forth
but not the decision maker as to the
appointment of the three police
commissioners
in the city and so we're asking
that um the committee consider passing
hp 88 so that we can rectify this
and make this housekeeping measure
permanent um
to go forward and have the city council
authority
uh for appointment instead of just only
the city manager
uh and that concludes uh my presentation
but i
i was welcome to questions on that
better
before we go to questions representative
do you have any written testimony to
submit
um i have no testimony that's just my um
presentation remarks relative to uh the
bill thank you
any questions from the committee for
representative stapleton
representative manager goody has her
hand up
please go ahead mr chair sorry that and
the question is not for
uh representative stapleton but i wanted
to get the blue sheet sign
up for the first bill hb 79
at the end of the hearing how many
signed up for and against thank you
this particular bill uh we have
four support one neutral
for uh hospital 88.
are there any other questions
representative stapleton if not i'm
going to move on to the next speaker
do you have a question mr chair
representative reporter yes thank you
thank you mr chair and representative
stapleton
um my memory is getting bad but i seem
to remember that we this was a bill that
we
dealt with in this committee last year
um without a problem do you know if
that's accurate
right um that was hp 1443
a committee of moved on to pass 14 to 3.
right thank you that's what i thought it
died
died with the pandemic so thank you
okay uh representative manager putin you
have another question
no sorry i forgot to lower my hand i
will do that
okay next we'll hear from
representative o'vern
oh i'm sorry good yep
go right ahead
good morning i'm representative andrew
o'hearn uh sullivan
three ward one clam on good morning mr
chair and fellow representatives
and obviously representative stapleton
has filled you in on the entire
bill it is exactly what it was last year
in 1443
the only correction i think i would make
is that the
council will appoint the police
commission but i don't believe
uh if i remember right that the city
manager will be part of the
police commission it would just be the
three members
uh without the city manager but i'll
take any questions if you have any
any questions from representative o'hara
seeing none uh representative clutier
are you on the line
and would like to speak
here mr chair okay all right those are
the only speakers that i have uh
listed that indicated they wanted to
speak are there any members of the
public
who would like to speak on this
issue on this bill
seeing none we'll close the hearing
on house bill 88
mr chair i have a procedural quest
question for you if that's all right
yes go ahead um i'm uh
prime sponsor of a bill we're hearing
this after a little while
but i did not sign up online to
um present the bill to the committee do
do i need to do that online for the
bills that i'm the sponsor of and i
would be introducing
or do you automatically call the person
who's introducing the bill
well that's my practice but i don't
think
i can speak for the chair of the
committee that you'll be addressing i
would
no this this is for this committee today
this afternoon
i mean a little while if 383 i didn't
sign up to
to present the bill i'll certainly give
you that courtesy and uh okay thank you
very much i appreciate it
i just didn't think i had to do that but
i'm still learning
we all uh so i'm gonna
take this next couple of minutes before
we start the next hearing give a little
public announcement you probably
saw my mask it says vaccinated on it
i would encourage certainly your own
decision but i would encourage
all our fellow members to vaccinate if
you can i was vaccinated this week with
the modern
version of the vaccine i had no side
effects but i'm told the second
shot may give me a case of the man flu
which i will
i will completely uh um
exploit into chicken soup and probably a
hot fudge sundae
to help me through it but i would i
would encourage
people to consider uh based on your
on good science and whatever your
current health condition is whether or
not you
want to get the shot the other thing i
wanted to talk to you about
is just a reminder of
our mask policy while in the building
most of you aren't here today but so you
might
you might not be used to the mass policy
if you do come to the lob
that there are three ways it's strictly
enforced
and violent violators of the mass policy
will be reported or can be reported to
the speaker's office
and there's three primary violations
that we are looking for to keep us
all safe one is that if you're in your
seat
like i am right now you can take your
mask off you'll see that most of the
time i have mine on anyway
but that's the only time it's a
violation if you get up out of your seat
and move about without your mask on
also if you're within six feet of
another person
without your mask on that's a that's a
violation
and thirdly if you go to a common area
like
a hallway or a restroom or stairway
you must wear your mask having you mask
off in that area is also a violation and
is affordable to the speaker's office
so it's strictly enforced not to be
overly punitive but to protect the
safety
of each other as we navigate through
this
terrible pandemic hopefully the light at
the end of the tunnel is coming
but please be safe also
tomorrow we have another session just
like today where we have
hearings in the morning and we have
executive session in the afternoon
tomorrow will be snowing
in new hampshire it looks like we got
finally engaged with the winter season
so if you are traveling i'd ask you to
be safe and you're always welcome to
zoom to the meeting
and if you don't feel safe traveling on
the roads so please be safe
okay with that uh i'm going to recess
for the next three minutes and we will
start at 10 o'clock
with house bill 183
so just please relax we'll we'll we are
on
we are live to the public and the mics
are hot
so please keep that
speaking of chris true he's the sponsor
did i see representative true it was in
here he was
just checking
mr chairman
someone mr chairman this is rich lasalas
i just wanted to make sure that you got
me on the
the attendance yes
thank you thank
yep
i was trying to make you a co-host mr
chair and for some reason
i couldn't do that but i will ask
christina if she can make your phone
i can do that sure thanks christina
thank you again for your help
any time it's like big sister watching
us at all times it's
such a comfort
christina has a voice made for video
thank you i've been practicing some
minor
sound issues today i think the meeting's
going quite well
the the i.t individual i didn't catch
his name when he came in he was
very quick to troubleshoot and i guess i
was the problem
i don't know what he did to my computer
but he fixed it pretty quick
well it's probably not the first time
you've seen the problem
right
how much snow are we supposed to get
tomorrow i heard
another like look like it was last night
another
two to four
and then again i think on friday
another batch yeah so
we're making up for january i know that
the people on derry are complaining
about the public works
efficiency you know you have the same
problem in london
yeah we have uh actually
our roads are very well cared
but by for the state and um we have a
lot of state roads
as dairy does to come through the state
of the regular job
but our biggest problem usually tends to
be
ice storms we have hilly roads
and if they get icy you know get salt on
right away
we get people off the roads
well i came back yesterday from antrim
and i only saw one car off the road
until i got into london
and then i had saw four oh wow so
it's one of those things very rough
obviously the roads are a little slicker
in london
in those houses
here he is this is the sponsor just came
in
[Music]
let's see the best place you would
probably be
um
if you want to get a chair over there or
you can you can sit over here to
representative true
all right i'm going to open the uh the
hearing on house bill 183
which is a bill prohibiting
municipalities from requiring a license
for a lemonade stand operated by a
person under the age of 18.
and we have representative true who is
the sponsor of the bill and
he has been testified i thank you
good morning mr chair
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee
for the record i am representative chris
true rockingham
district 4 with the towns of auburn
chester and sandown thank you very much
for this opportunity to introduce
house bill 183 enact prohibiting
municipalities from requiring a license
for a lemonade stand operated by a
person under the age of 18.
i have submitted this bill not because
new hampshire has a large number of
cities
sending their health departments to
break up children's lemonade stands
in fact i do not know of any towns in
new hampshire
shutting down lemonade stands of
children
the goal of hb 183 is to ensure that
lemonade stands of children in new
hampshire
will not ever be shut down by any town
please know that i included lemonade
only lemonade stands in the bill because
i wanted to keep it as simple as
possible
hb 183 is now in the possession of the
committee
and it is certainly your decision as to
whether you wish to also include
in the bill kool-aid xylax physies or
any other terminology that the committee
feels is best
new hampshire is a dylan's rule state
and thus new hampshire defines
what it will grant to the local
governments
hb 183 clearly states that the new
hampshire towns will not have the
authority
to license and regulate lemonade stands
of children
i hope that the committee agrees that
there is not any need
for the state of new hampshire to grant
to a local government
the authority to control and regulate
children's lemonade stands
i ask for your support for house bill
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
thank you representative uh do you have
uh
some testimony i don't believe yourself
could you keep a copy to the clerk
i will thank you are there questions
uh from the committee uh for
representative
yes representative gallagher has his
hand up
yes so um
so if
you said you can't think of any examples
of
cities that have already
tried to shut down lemon lemonade stands
then may i ask
what exactly was it that inspired
this bill like what why might
it even become an issue in the future
that
uh why that a city might want to shut
down a lemonade stand
uh thank you for the question while
officer legislative services could not
find any instances in new hampshire
they have found many instances of
health departments or towns sending
their police forces
to shut down a children's lemonade stand
there was even a case i believe it was a
lemonade manufacturer
who pledged something like ten thousand
dollars to defend children
who uh who were fined
for operating without a permit or a
license
that just seems far
far too overboard too heavy-handed
and it's those actions that that's why
i've introduced the bill
so such actions do not happen in new
hampshire
okay for representative manchapudi
because i think i'm going to anticipate
the question you're going to ask
this bill uh of the people that signed
in report
are supporting it nine support one
opposed
did you have any other comments that you
have to unmute
i do i do have a question for uh
prime sponsor uh representative true
so you know i i am glad
this is not in existence in new
hampshire
having two kids in my neighborhood
kids having lemonade which i encouraged
and supported
and they did well uh knowing that i
didn't violate i'm happy
but by stating
that this is not an issue in new
hampshire
but yet you're trying to prevent
um do you think that is
making or shining the spotlight on this
issue so it would become an issue or
is it i'm just trying to figure out
why you why
you thought about this
thank you for the question
has uh has uh ordinances
where they require uh peddlers
and hawkers of wares as such to uh to
apply for a permit
to uh for a day
i i believe it was something like fifty
dollars a day that they would have to
apply for a permit for
if nashua decided that they had
a uh a need
to cease all children's lemonade stands
they could use that ordinance to uh to
call for
uh a 50 permit to be issued
for a kid to run a lemonade stand where
he might make a couple of dollars
and because we are a dylan rule state
knowing that a city could do this if
they so
chose to my position is
i don't think that's the new hampshire
way for
a health department to go and shut down
a kid's lemonade stand or kool-aid stand
for over overreaching reasons
next up we have representative porter
and then we'll go to representative
state thank you mr chair and thank you
representative
true for listening to my question um
the bill specifically says that any
a lemonade stand operated by a person
under the age of 18.
so if i were a 25 year old and i wanted
to set up a stand
to make money but i didn't want to spend
fifty dollars for a license
my town required could i then hire
a 17 year old to run the stand for me
operate the stand for me so that it
wouldn't get shut down
under under the terms of this bill
um yes i guess if
if you owned a home in nashua
and you wanted to hire a 17 year old kid
to sit out in your front lawn
with his lemonade stand and
sell lemonade um
you could do that i can't imagine why
somebody would hire
somebody to sit on their lawn to sell
lemonade but
yes you you could hire a 17 year old
i guess in the hopes that he would make
more than two or three dollars a day
selling lemonade
reporter you had a follow-up yes i do
because i'm a little puzzled by this in
hillsborough um we often have a balloon
festival
um and one of the most uh
visited stands at the balloon festival
is the lemonade fresh lemonade stand
where the person is mixing
the sugar water in the lemons right in
front of you and they charge 3.50 cents
to five dollars
for a glass of lemonade um that
certainly isn't a stand in front of my
house
but under the provision of this bill
would that
lemonade stand not be able to be shut
down
by the town if it didn't have a license
um i'm not familiar with
i can't hear you i'm sorry sir i'm not
familiar with your area of new hampshire
so i don't know what
your town would charge a
peddler or a hawker to set up a lemonade
stand
i guess it all depends on on how much
money you thought you could make uh
setting up
a lemonade stand for for a day or
or however long you wanted to set it up
for um
i am in no way talking about uh
extreme situations where somebody is
going to try to save himself a
whatever whatever the permit is a a ten
dollar permit
where he would have to hire somebody
a teenager pay them something um
that's not the situation that i
envisioned at all i envisioned
children like i did when i was a child
setting uh a table out and uh and
selling uh selling
lemonade to uh people in my neighborhood
who happened to walk by
next we'll go to representatives davis
then we'll
have representative mcdonald and
representative gilman in that order
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative drew for taking my
question
um under this bill if i
were a child and i wanted to have a bake
sale
would that also be um
exempt from any prohibition from the
town or is it
is it specific to lemonade and if it's
specific to lemonade
why thank you thank you for the question
um yes it is specific to lemonade
and as i said before the reason i made
it specifically for lemonade
is because i'm not trying to get
children to sell clothing
or baked goods
all i want a child to be able to do in
new hampshire
is set up a table in front of their
house
and sell lemonade that that's why i only
made it lemonade i wanted to keep the
bill as clean
and as simple as possible
thank you representative
i have experience and i did a lot of the
stuff when i was 10k and i was just
graduating
setting up lemonade stands at their home
why not make it a little bit younger
like
13 you know under or something like that
where they would be working at it but
also setting a stand up front
on their phone thank you for the
question as i said i mean
the bill is no longer mine it is in in
your hands and you can certainly i would
not object to that
the reason i chose under 18
is because that is a child at 18 you're
an adult
in new hampshire under 18 that that's
why that's why i chose
that particular age i would certainly
have no objection
to the committee lowering it um
for whatever age they felt was more
appropriate
i just picked under 18 because
you were still a child
uh thank you mr chair and thank you
representative true uh my question is
about this
statute originally is enabling and
towns and our towns can make a decision
on what they want to
regulate as far as hawkers and vendors
on the streets so
that would make this lemonade
issue still a town issue town to town
issue is that correct
if if this would have become law
uh yes towns would still have
ordinances regulating hawkers and
federers and all that
but obviously what they could not have
is the requirement that a ten-year-old
child
get a 50 permit to sell lemonade
that's what they would not be able to do
they would still still be able to
to regulate other businesses in their
town
right sorry i missed the word prohibited
thank you
thank you is there anyone else perhaps
from the public that would like to
weigh in on this bill
a very similar bill came to this
committee last year
and while it was
viewed as being well attention and
actively considered i believe that the
build was not supported
primarily for a um
or what i would call a minor reason and
that is
uh we get caught up in the issue of why
just lemonade
what if what if the child wanted to sell
a glass of water or coca-cola
or kool-aid uh why
why would we just single out lemonade so
we're going to exact this bill tomorrow
afternoon and they're
prepared an amendment that you all
should have a copy of that
that executes a minor change
in the bill where it calls out lemonade
the amendment just changes that to soft
drinks so if someone wants to sell
kool-aid
orange juice or whatever water
uh it would all be uh i'll be
captured under this bill so that's
that's coming tomorrow
afternoon any other questions
from representative true while he's
still here i don't have any other anyone
else
that's asked to speak and in deference
to
representative manjuputi this is
supported nine to one for those who have
uh oh we do have a representative van
has as a question yes please go ahead
thank you uh chairman nolan dolan uh
this is actually a question for
representative true
um correct me if i'm wrong but
since we are a dylan's rule state and
since
cities and towns already have the
ability to
regulate hawkers and peddlers
i'm not clear why we need to single out
children's lemonade stands
as a thing that has to be dealt with in
a particular way
can you help me with that
thank you for the question um
in my opinion there is a uh
there is a history of little kids
setting up lemonade stands
for to get some pocket money
um i think any uh
any effort to regulate that with a
fifty dollar pedaller's fee is
overhanded
uh it's just too heavy-handed
um right now as a i believe
a town could say we will only allow
a kid to sell lemonade on the front lawn
if they pay a fifty dollar headless fee
this being a dillon state
would say no you can't
we would take away that that authority
from
uh from the cities and towns to say
to sell lemonade in our town uh a
ten-year-old must pay a fifty or a
hundred dollar
headless fee they would know what if
this passes they would no longer have
that authority to do that
the state would take away that authority
uh follow up if i may
uh has any town
enforced or threaten to enforce
or put on the books any such
ordinance i i'm just trying to determine
how pressing this
is i asked
ols to do research for me and they could
not find
any instance in new hampshire where this
has happened yet
they found many instances throughout the
country
where in some cases children were
fined for violating a city ordinance
that is what i am trying to avoid ever
happening
here in new hampshire because i don't
see that as being
anywhere close to being the new
hampshire way
okay are there any questions uh from the
public that would like to weigh in on
this issue
we haven't heard from yet or any anyone
else on the committee that
like to ask an additional question
seeing none uh just as a reminder we
will be executing this bill
uh tomorrow afternoon uh and our next
uh hearing thank you representative
thank you thank you my next hearing
will be on house bill 332 which
considers the deadlines for developments
of regional impact by planning boards
uh that hearing will start at 10 30 so
we're going to be
and please mind your manners
okay let's uh get restarted this is the
municipal and county government
committee
we are now at the point in the schedule
where
we're going to hear testimony on house
bill 332
which is relative to deadlines for
consideration of developments or
regional
impact by planning boards i believe we
have
mr graves here to speak
mr chad i apologize for interrupting but
i do see that representative seaworth is
here now
and you have asked okay maybe you go
first i
yes he's the prime sponsor so i'd like
to ask
representative us to open up for us i
see you
you indicate that you want to speak for
10 minutes
do you have a written testimony to
submit to the committee
we may have mr chair a slight problem
because mr seaworth is using an older
version of zoom
it's uh i have to promote him to
panelists and i'm unable to do that
without getting an error
code if maybe one of us could
uh in the interim while i
try to sort that out have one i've
sorted it out for you you should be
available
thank you miss dyer um i apologize for
that i have a chromebook
and it doesn't play well with some of
the
zoom features well you're up so we hear
you well so go ahead and give us your
testimony
all right and i don't have a written
version of this
um but thank you mr chairman
um and thank you to the committee for
taking the time to hear my bill this
morning
my name is brian seaworth i am from
pembroke
i represent the district that includes
pembroke and chichester and
i am the prime sponsor of hb
332. um this
bill proposes to make a simple change
to the law
so that there's parity between planning
board
applications with and without a finding
that the application is a development of
regional impact
briefly just to get into the terms
the development of regional impact is a
way within the rsas for regional
planning that a planning board can
acknowledge that a project
impacts other communities outside of its
own jurisdiction
so if a planning board determines that
an application
is a dri then the affected communities
plus the regional planning commission
which is appropriate will be notified as
a butters for the plan
um when you do this there's some
specific
overhead uh administrative it's
specified in the
in the rsa and that will end up delaying
when the application gets worked on
typically it's for
one meeting cycle to explain why i think
this bill is necessary
i think it'll be fastest just to
go through my own experience with this i
am
also wearing a different hat the chair
of my town's planning board
and we had an experience uh it happened
in the fall of 2019
um an application came in we were
actually familiar with it we
we knew the property we knew the
developer they had had a previous
application on this
and so we knew that it was going to be a
dri
and the applicant was of course eager to
expedite things they asked us if there
were
any shortcuts to the process um
our town's planner ended up putting a
lot of time in
having a lot of discussion we worked
through legal
i spent some time reviewing the rsas and
ultimately we decided we had to follow
the process
as the rsas required it so what happened
we met
um it was right after thanksgiving 2019
we had a meeting we accepted the
application is complete
we determined that it was
a regional impact
which then sent motion the process for
notification for that um
now our planning board we review
applications monthly
uh the the fourth week of each month
with one exception
in december every year because of the
christmas holiday
we move our meeting forward so what
happened was there was no way
for us to continue that meeting from
november to the december meeting
because the deadlines didn't allow it
so we continued to january you all had a
merry
christmas happy new year came back in
january
um opened the hearing on the process now
with the regional impact notification
having gone
out and well the first thing we had to
discuss
was that the 65-day requirement
for a planning board to complete review
on an application and make a decision
was now due to expire within the week
so our discussion was well is the
applicant uh willing to extend the time
for review
um to make a long story short it just
it set a bad tone for the application
and we spent a good
chunk of that first month's hearing
discussing issues around around the
delay
so putting on my other hat as i
explained to the planning board why we
got into this and why the law required
doing what we did i offered um
to come up with a bill come up with some
legislation that would address this
problem
i think if this bill's enacted it would
simply automatically do what's going to
happen
anyway through the process that's
outlined in the rsas
so i think it'll simply smooth the
process along all around
make sure that the applicant the board
and everyone spends less time
on compliance with the rsa and more time
reviewing the application
um so with that again i'll thank you for
uh
hearing this bill this morning i hope
you find that it makes sense and
recommend
its passage and i'm happy to take any
questions
okay uh before we uh
take questions just to to let you all
know
of the signing on this bill on 332
there were four sign ins two supported
it
one oppose it and one is neutral
we're going to hear next from uh mr
craze from
nhma but before we go mr grades is there
anyone on the committee that has
questions for representative seaworth
okay seeing none can we bring up mr
graves
thank you mr chair uh i'm nature grays
from the new hampshire municipal
association
and uh we do oppose this bill as written
but we are more than happy to work with
the sponsor to
uh accomplish what he's attempting to do
here
um and the reason we we oppose it um
is because that uh
it doesn't i it doesn't seem to
do what the sponsor wants it to do um in
that
uh once it changes the the language of
rsa
676 colon 4 and adds in
some wording so that it says upon the
determination by the planning board
the board that a submitted application
is complete according to the board's
regulations
or in the case of development of
regional impact upon the commencement of
the public hearing pursuant to rsa 3657
but when you go to rsa 3657 that's
the the board's required review
of a development to determine whether it
has a regional impact
and there's no actual hearing required
under that
so the way this is written it looks like
it's referencing a hearing which doesn't
actually occur so
it doesn't seem to accomplish what the
sponsor wants to accomplish which is to
speed up the process here
and as i said i'm more than happy to
work with the sponsor to
try to to to come up with some language
that would
um that would accomplish what he's
trying to accomplish here
thank you mr graves are there any
questions from the committee
for mr grace from the nhma on his on his
testimony
yes uh representative manchipudi
thank you mr chair like i said i'm
staying true to my
conscience of asking questions being the
first uh
time on this committee uh my question to
you
uh representative from new hampshire
municipal association is
how does this shift the responsibility
or ownership of local control versus
state or is there any way that this will
bring uniformity
amongst the municipalities that
we have in new hampshire so
i don't know that it really
does that um the way
that the process currently works is um
you know if you're going to submit
something like let's say a grocery store
and it's right on the border of two
towns um
and so you submit it to the town that
you're in and the planning board looks
at it and says okay well this is
obviously going to have a regional
impact because it's going to affect our
neighbors the municipality next door
more traffic etc so we're going to
provide them notice
and then once they have received notice
they have the opportunity to
give us input about how that's going to
affect their community
just as any sort of any abutter would do
um or anyone else with
a a a right to um talk about it it's
basically to notify the municipality to
say hey
you know thanks to this grocery store
we're going to have you know estimated
double the amount of traffic on the
street or whatever the case may be
um and that's
the current process and it seems like
what happened in representative
seaworth's case is that they ran into
a a problem with the
65 day deadline to
act upon the application mainly because
of the holidays and how everything
worked out there
and it certainly seems like the purpose
is to try to give some more flexibility
here to
the local planning board to ensure that
it can start this process a little bit
sooner
if it knows that it's going to be a
regional impact
sooner and therefore not run afoul that
65 days so still keep
still keep the entire process um
short within within that period but give
them the opportunity to start
notifications a little bit earlier
and that's that seems to be the intent
as he explained it
although um if i misunderstood that
i'd certainly like representative
seaworth to correct me
okay next we have a a question from
representative klee
thank you um my actual questions have
been answered but
um when i read this over and i'm sorry
i meant to mention it earlier line 19
the word platt is that supposed to be
plan
i believe it's supposed to be plat um
because because that's the um what
they're what they're called
in the other statutes
okay thank you i just i as as
representative mender putin mentioned um
i2m new to this and
had not heard that term so it's a term i
will look up
thank you so much okay
on this particular bill of those
who signed in uh we have two that
support one of hoses and one is neutral
are there any other questions for those
that are testifying
is there anybody from the public that
would like to weigh in on this
none we will
enter a recess and pick up our next bill
at 11 o'clock
house bill number 380 which is relative
to the election of grafton
representative we have lost audio we
didn't hear the end of that
i'm sorry can you hear me now yes the
audio came back um i just think
we missed what you were saying were you
just recessing until
the next bill i'm recessing to the next
bill 11 o'clock
and i just reminded everybody that the
mics are hot and be careful
uh you don't put something out over the
airways that you don't intend to great
thank you
ship is yours mr chair thank you
we'll see that's like we have
the sign supposed to be pointed toward
the camera or the uh
chair yes ned cord it represented enough
yes we do we gotta go to him first
yeah we're gonna fire up
okay again good morning this is the
municipal and county government
committee
at the state house and we are about to
consider
a hearing on house bill 380
which is relative to the election of
grafton county commissioners
on the sign in list
we have six sign ins
five in support zero opposed and one is
neutral
and before as we start we're gonna uh
start with representative ned gordon
representative gordon do you have any
written testimony to submit
if you haven't already
sorry i'm actually up at dartmouth
hitchcock right now and
uh so i'm a little bit difficult
situation but
uh for the record my name is ned gordon
and i represent grafton county district
and i am the prime sponsor of this bill
this bill passed the house in its
current form
last session and went over to the senate
and then died in the senate as a result
of the covet issues
it what it does it's very it's very
simple
and what it does is create a rotating
term
for one of the three grafton county
commissioners
one commissioner at all times would
serve a four-year term
the purpose of doing so is to prevent
the situation which has occurred in the
past
where you have three brand new
commissioners
all elected contemporaneously and none
has
any history or background with regard to
the operation of the county
uh we found that that is not a good
circumstance not a good situation
and so the idea is to provide continuity
i understand that other counties may
have similar type arrangements
we would start with the commissioner and
it would start with the election
in 2022
with district one and that particular
commissioner would serve
four years and then each of the
commissioner districts would rotate
after that
so you would have one commissioner
serving a four-year term at all times
and that's the very simple purpose of
the bill
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
for representative gordon
on the bill as he's testified yes so
representative gallagher has a question
so we had another bill
previously last week about
rockingham county wanting to move
some of their elections or
their officers term likes to be
four years as well um since
this bill does something similar to it
is there any possibility that they could
be combined at all
all right obviously we'd like to see
this bill move forward
but if you found it was more convenient
to combine the two bills
and they did the same thing serve the
same purpose
i'm not sure there would be any
objection to that
mr chairman yes representative got
creating we're going to take out
at a later time i think that might be
the bill of referring to
nothing covers county commissions it
counts it covers the other
county offices it might be difficult
to marry the truth together
thank you for that
are there any other questions from
representative
morgan yes representative
yes thank you mr chair i'd like to take
my question
of president um what is the term
now for the county commissions uh
each county commissioner serves a
two-year term
so they're elected every two years
are up for election on every two years
and there have been circumstances
where all three of our commissioners
we have three brand new commissioners
again
none with any history of the county
so there's no possible way that you can
make
your county commissioners work
alternating your two years and keeping
uh two on and one uh elected and then
next year next session do the same thing
you feel this is much easier is that
what you're saying well
in effect that's what this bill does it
makes sure that you always have
one commissioner that has continuity
that's going to be there
and isn't up for re-election in that
second year
thank you okay next question from
representative trill 11 and then we'll
go to main
representative major goody after that
things to do thank you mr chair and
thanks mr
representative gordon for coming to
testify um following up on
representative gallagher's question
i think i want to note that the
rockingham county commissioners
bill change number i don't recall came
to us
wanting all commissioners to be
four-year terms
and this would be just one commissioner
four-year term i i understand what the
county is trying to do
um to retain some count
continuity i'm not sure they can go
together and as another
uh testifier has said earlier today you
know now that it's our bill we can
look at them and and see what we think
um
my only comment thank you
if if i could just respond i i think
there was a consensus that we liked the
fact that
in most cases county commissioners are
elected for
a two-year term and but
there was a need for that continuity
that's why we're only rotating one of
the commissioner's terms
for four years good thank you
uh and next we have a question from
representative manager rudy
thank you mr t thank you representative
gordon for taking my question
um so if you're saying one commissioner
is going to serve four so over
three cycles all three commissioners
will be serving four year term
isn't it or is it just if it's going to
be rotating
and my second question uh
is also how does that change the statute
that's
in existence right now
well that's exactly what the bill does
it changes the statute the statute
currently says that each
commissioner serves a two-year term and
this would just change it so that one of
the commissioners would serve a
four-year term and you were correct
that they would be that it would rotate
among the
districts starting with district one and
then two and then three
so over uh a set of
three elections you would rotate
the uh that four-year term
can i have a follow-up mr chair yes go
right ahead
uh so this is i mean the
two-year term for commissioners three
commissioners is a uniform across
all uh counties and
um why just start with one
i represent hillsborough county and it
is the same
issue with all the counties how about if
you know uh all other uh every
uh elected position except the u.s
senate
uh it's all two-year terms so it's
it's going to just carve out one pitch
how can we justify
that
representative
uh incorrect but at least one other
county who has already
gone to this uh rotating scheme
for county commissioners
which one i didn't hear his audio is not
which
county has already gone i think uh
representative gordon i think you cut
out from the audio
part of your response could you redo it
yes
i i don't um i i can't tell you which
county
but it's my understanding that at least
one other county
has already gone to this type of
rotating longer term
in order to for the same purpose and
that we've already at the legislature's
already done this in the
okay past you uh any other questions
from representative gordon
okay seeing none i'm going to close the
hearing
on this bill thank you very much
thank you thank you for your testimony
that
closes the hearing for house bill 380.
uh just a quick comment from the chair
uh
those of you who are on zoom uh
i only need to see you if we're going to
be voting
an executive session if you need click
off your video
take care of personal business or
uh get up and move around or whatever
that's that's certainly fine
um feel free to turn off your video
which is
should be an option for you down in the
bottom corner of your screen
i'd only need to see you if we're in a
boating mode
and but other than that feel free to
turn off your video
and go go about your business and you
have to
go to the bathroom or get some to eat
order
okay uh we have some time now we have
almost 20 minutes before the next bill
so
i think to make better use of our time
i'm going to collapse a little bit of
the schedule that we're going to be
seeing
this afternoon now i have a request from
the ranking member
of the reporter to move to hp 586
as our first bill to exec this afternoon
is that is that request still standing
representative yes i would appreciate
that mr chair
i'm not sure if the bill i was going to
testify on has
been recessed i'm waiting to hear that
but it would
ease my mind if i knew i could be with
with our committee when we vote on that
bill
all right so i'm going to uh look at
this afternoon's
exact session i'm going to try to pull
in
hb 101 which is relative to the close of
a county's
books of records
so representative mcdonald do you have a
a motion you'd like to make
yes yeah i believe since i've submitted
an
amendment we will have to vote on that
amendment first
which changed the uh time frame from 30
to
45 days
okay you have the do you have the number
of the amendment
that we can reference it
excuse me mr chair are we in an
executive session now
yes we will be going into executive
session i'm just uh
okay thank you cleaning up some
documents at this point before we go
okay i have i have the intent
okay so we are now in executive session
considering house bill 101
uh the first thing we're going to do is
we have a
motion by representative mcdonald
on
one 2021-016 four h
you wanna speak speak to that you wanna
make the motion and then speak to the
amendment
all right yes mr chairman let me just
get that number to you one more time
2021-01648
uh thank you mr chairman uh
when i originally uh did this this bill
i put in 30 30 days
and talked to one of my commissioners
they requested that i increase it to 45
days
which i didn't see any problems with
that
what i hope to do with this is to try to
put some incentive to get the uh
the books closed a little bit earlier
and also to uh
keep on my particular county moving
forward and doing that
i think by having them contact um
revenue governor administration that
will give them incentives for
everyone to get our honor
to say we just completed our 2019 audit
uh about a month or so ago
so is your motion to accept the
amendment as presented
yes that would decrease to 45 days is
there a second on that
exactly yes we have a second
yes
is there any discussion on the amendment
seeing none you want to take the roll
call on
voting on the amendment
yes
representative clee
yes representative tripp
representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas yes
representative mcbride yes
yes representative
yes
yes majority
yes davis
yes representative
19-0 on the amendment so now we have
uh house bill 101 amended
is there a motion to otp
the the bill as amended
to be otp as amended for a second
okay mr clerk if you call the roll
on the otp the bill as amended
uh representative monty yes
representative porter
yes
uh
videos
yes
can you hear me
vote yes
yes representative melvin
yes representative
yes uh representative power
yes representative gallagher
yes uh representative
yes representative
yes majority yes
representative established davis yes
policies uh representative mccoody
yes brother
yes without objection i will place this
on the consent
count
okay we still have another 10 minutes
house bill 459 is the uh
the bill that prohibits the transfer of
funds within an adopted budget
to the general legend line when the when
the entry has zero dollars
we do have a an amendment
do we have it no i don't have it here we
don't have it yet okay
pardon me while i i check to see if i
have it
you know i'm accelerating the calendar
here
bear with me
i'm happy yet
mr chair have we gotten copies of this
amendment
no i was just checking to see if i got a
copy and i don't so it's still
it looks like it's still in process
so let's move on to
house bill 445.
this is a bill that
[Music]
has to do with competitive bidding and
cattle counting
and we have some input
that this bill may have some legal
problems and
what i what i think we ought to do is i
think
we ought to retain this bill put it in
front of legal
counsel let them open on it and then we
take it back and
either change the bill make it legal
or accept it as is but i think
rather than putting a potentially
compromised bill in front of the house i
would like to see the committee agree to
retain the bill
and let legal go through it make sure
that there aren't any problems with it
but i'll open for discussion if anyone
would like to
opine on that thought so we would hold
the bill and work on it over the summer
and
deal with it next year is that how that
works
not hearing you mr chair i'm sorry i
can't hear you
is that
that puts an echo in there you hear me
now
that's better yes we can hear you so uh
what we can do is we can retain it
until legal gives us an opinion and then
we can put it back on our account we
don't have to wait till next year
are you sure i'm not sure
my understanding of a retained bill is
that we retain it
to work over the summer and and vote um
take it up again in the fall
and in the second year we interim study
and do the same thing
but don't take it up for a vote because
the session is over
well let's do this because i'm not sure
so
i don't uh we just plan on
taking it off the exact calendar
let's let me get some uh let me get an
expert opinion on how we
either going to retain it or just move
it out to the future a little bit
it's not an early bill is it mr chairman
i i think if you call the clerk he would
be able to answer that question for us
too
representative uh dole dolan i'm more
than happy to
check in on that for you thank you
um mr chair i have a question about this
process
as well thank you
um i think i heard you say that
we would we would retain the bill get a
legal opinion on it and then
fix the bill isn't it
up to the sponsor to do that not the
committee
what we would do is well once
once it's an executive session it's our
bill it's not the sponsor's ability
so we could we could fix it with an
amendment or
we could itl the bill if it's too it's
too badly flawed or whatever
so it really becomes our when it's an
executive session it really becomes our
fail
it's not no longer the sponsor's bill
that's a somewhat of a nuanced uh
answer but that's that's the way it
feels
nice but to your point though i think
that if we found a flaw like that we
would certainly want to engage with the
sponsor
so that we retain the intent of them
all right so um
so house bill 445 will not be exact this
afternoon
until we uh unless we get an opinion
real quick
on how to retain but i'm
thinking that we'll push that out
at least till tomorrow
mr chair we used to have an old saying
in
municipal and county that we do
we do tune-ups not engine overhauls
just so that was what i was learning
early on
there's also one i heard though if it's
a bad bill don't fix it
kill it so uh
with that advice uh i
i certainly uh don't disagree
uh the next bill to be exact is
house bill 560 which is the election of
rockingham county officials
there any discussion about that before
we move into that
that bill do you remember that we heard
that bill
last week
does anybody remember that
yes i remember
sure it looks like representative power
has her hand up
yes representative power please go ahead
thank you chairman dolan for um taking
my um question so
my concern is with regard to this bill
is that
it changes the term of the election of
all county offices in rockingham to four
years
and so my concern would be is what are
the ramifications are
what it would be the effect for
rockingham
counties elected officers
to be four years whereas in other
counties within the state
it would be different is is this is this
a concern
or is it a non-concern
good point let's let's
leave that question on the table and see
if we can she wanted a bit uh
representatively you had a comment
uh yeah um pardon my uh um
the the comment that i have is kind of a
question
the last bill that we had that was
similar to this
in public hearing a comment was made
that other
counties are doing something similar but
when asked
directly what counties that answer
couldn't be given
i would feel more comfortable to know
what counties are
doing things similar with their
commissioners and and so on
before we voted on this um perhaps
someone from this committee does
know that answer um and and i do have
concerns that we're and i know someone's
got to be an example but that we're
piecemealing
from county to county to county and not
um
trying to keep things similar um
so i do have some issues with that thank
you thank you
representative tripp uh thank you for
taking my uh
that's not a question it's a statement
uh if
the uh if you look at the uh uh
i'll say 653 colon one this is the uh
uh the uh
rsa that's been amended by this uh
or change of this uh bill
and uh if you if you look at uh
section 6
e it says that sullivan county does the
two
two four term for commissioners
uh rockingham county does it two
two four for commissioners and uh
it appears that merrimack county does
the same also
so there's there's a precedent for
having
different terms
in counties within the state
okay so we have a precedent
um representative power you have a
follow-up
um yes i would like to um answer
representative
cle's inquiry so in preparation for the
hearing for this bill i did do research
and presently in new hampshire the
counties of carroll
um cheshire sullivan belknap rockingham
american
merrimack and koas they have the
four-year two-year rotating terms
and this was all
put on the books beginning in 1980 for
cheshire
and i have dates for all of them and the
most recent
um i believe i'm looking at my notes
here it was merrimack
in 1996. so therefore
all counties within the state have this
four-year two-year rotating term
except presently for hillsborough
grafton and stratford
they still have the two-year terms for
all three
commissioners
having non-congruent terms across the
counties
yes representative may i also i'm just
follow up with with a comment so based
on that information with regard to this
bill
i would be comfortable in um
having an amendment such that the
county commissioner for rockingham um
would have let me see
no i x i take that back nope i'm all set
thank you
representative mcdonald do we have an
amendment already on this uh i thought
we were supposed to receive
well i haven't i haven't seen it i'm
just thinking about that
okay yes uh representatives davis
uh thank you mr chair for taking my
question
uh my question has to do with the format
of the structure of this bill
as it's been presented to us as i read
653-1
all of the counties that have
lengths of terms for specific offices
are simply listed in alphabetical order
under letter a grafton and hillsborough
counties one county commissioner etc etc
i don't understand why this particular
bill
calls out except for rockingham county
why couldn't it just
follow the format of the others
and simply list the terms
i just don't understand why it should be
in a different
different wording in a different format
from the rest of the law
okay thank you representative
thank you mr chair i'm still a little
concerned because
we're talking different kinds of
officers
and my understanding from listening to
the the
previous testimony today the concern is
for
continuation of institutional knowledge
so that one ca one county commissioner
has a four-year term
and the others have two this bill
it isn't dealing with county
commissioners at all it's dealing with
the other offices
within the county um and so
i'm not sure that it it the rationale
for four years
is the same rationale as was given for
the four-year term
for county commissioners
[Music]
i understand the argument that was given
for the four-year terms for this bill
but i don't think we can equate the
county commissioner four-year term
with these i don't think they're
parallel
okay thank you any other comments from
the committee
we do have an amendment that's been
proposed
by representative wyler
to the bill and it
the amendment added county
it added one officer to yeah
amendment 2021-0187
h h is in hotel
one more time two 2021-0187
h
uh representative yes you have your hand
up
now you have to unmute though
here i am at my dining room table
serving as my slash office
completely confused
first of all what bill are we talking
about
this is bill 560 house bill
five 560 zero okay and do we have an
amendment or not
yes we have an amendment it's two zero
two one
dash zero one eight seven h so what are
we talking about now
that's bill that amends house bill 560.
i don't know i got it but in the
conversation are we talking about the
amendment or the bill
uh we're talking about both um
the the amendment is a uh
a very small change just adds one more
position as the treasurer to the to the
bill
okay now i understand where we are i'm
sorry i was off in the woods with the
cat
i'll be back now thank you
thank you uh representative manjapudi
you had your hand up
yes thank you for taking my question i
am i was confused as to what we were
addressing
and it seems like it's a piecemeal
hillsborough county coming from the
largest county in the state
you know the similar institutional
knowledge
and the election of every two years for
all the officers and changing that
does a fact and so
instead of changing the statue
at the state level why
each county is doing their own stuff and
this is
it just i'm not able to wrap my head
around that
okay good comment uh thank you
um so we we had this amendment
that would uh change some of the
language to add
the county treasurer as into the list of
of officials that this
this effects however
we will only vote on the amendment uh if
there's an
okay to proceed motion if it's a
inexpedient to legislate then the
amendment
is not in order we have a
hand up from representatives davis
thank you mr chair it's really not a
question it's a flippant comment
uh representative manjapudi welcome to
municipal and county government
yes it can it can be a kind of piecemeal
at times
uh any other questions or comments
yes representative guthrie thank you i'd
just like to make the comment that
uh you all recall that i think that
almost all of the officers that i
referred to in this bill did come
forward
didn't give us the same rationale which
was to
allow them to do their job better
instead of having to
uh campaign for their office uh the
second year that they were
in office so i just wanted to
remind a board that it was a
pretty much a unanimous presentation
by the uh by the people people holding
the office
and they use the same rationale
and it seemed to be fairly simple
as far as the bill was concerned well
thank you for that reminder
any other comments from the committee or
any comments
that's it we're not going to go to the
public we're just taking comments in the
community yes
representative powell is it is it
correct
that the commissioners in the state
there
they receive a stipend and not a salary
per se
whereas the other uh elected county
officers
they do receive a salary for their um
positions that's a good question
yeah i'm not sure if the the positions
listed here
uh receive some do i think some do
receive a salary
uh the elected officials don't they just
uh receive mileage and i think there's
an hourly rate that's also paid
to uh to elected officials also for
meetings
but uh like the treasurer the
registry of deeds the sheriff things
like that the county attorney they all
they do have a salary that they pay
representative porter um yes thank you
mr chair
all of those positions are elected it's
just the county delegation who doesn't
get
a salary not the county officers but
to the to the point that they all
expressed to us that they could do their
jobs better
if they had a four-year term rather than
a two-year term my
counter to that is i sure could have
done my job better with a four-year
term as well i think most of us would
prefer not to have to go out and
campaign
after two years of serving um it would
be much better for us
we could devote our time to our position
and not have to worry about that so
i'm sure they all would like to have a
four-year position just as i would like
to have a four-year position
um but i'm not sure in my mind still
that that's the best thing
for the people of the citizens of the
county
to not to have four-year terms for their
officers
okay so i'm going to open it up now oh
i'm sorry representative tripp
thank you mr chair uh i'm a little
confused too are we still waiting for a
motion on the uh the bill
yeah still in discussion we're still in
discussion but um
i was going to ask for a motion to
either itl or otp the bill
well i move otp hospital 560.
mr chairman yes we still got to do a
vote on the uh
whether you're accepting a number right
if you want if you want to do
an otp then we first have to uh attack
the amendment
okay then we would uh the motion would
be otp as i mentioned
okay so the amendment
uh are you interested in making a motion
on the amendment
i i moved uh to otp on the uh amendment
to house to 560.
that's amendment
eight seven 2021-01878 it's an amendment
to house bill 560 is there a second to
that motion
it's been seconded by representative
guthrie
would they ask the clerk to take the
role on the amendment
okay uh
representative yes
yes
representative mcbride yes
yes representative gallagher
yes uh representative
trail oven now that i have my head
screwed on straight
and i know what bill i'm talking about
an amendment yes
yes
okay now we're looking for a motion to
otp house bill 560 as amended
i moved uh to otg
house bill 560 as amended
it's been second
mr clerk please call the rollback
by the way does not pass
otp then i'll accept uh another an
additional motion
after that okay representative pimarti
yes no
representative
no representative
yes
yes uh representative power
no
representative gallagher no
uh representative gotta start somewhere
yes
representative gilman no
uh representative no
uh representative famous
roberto mangapudi no
representative green yes
[Music]
collect folks yes representative yes
uh pastor 11 through 8.
okay that cannot go on the consent
calendar uh i'm going to take a recess
for
for three three or four minutes
representative maggiore yes
would you please tell the clerk that i
would be glad to write the minority
report for this
bill i would be happy to thank you
i didn't know if he could hear me
well mr clark i'd be glad to write the
minority report for this
for this bill i think you wrapped it up
what
you're taking home my responsibility
he's okay
yes represent a trip you're going to
have to jump up and down
if you have your hand up well
you know it's interesting i sat back
there and i and i thought well
he doesn't see me because i'm all the
way back there
so i moved up here
yeah maybe i could sit there you know
these should be the worst problems we
have
amendment
representative maturi i just got an
email from representative suzanne smith
who said she had forward
representative gordon was
not sure he could testify and she had
signed up at nine this morning to
testify and present um
present in his place and she was
wondering why we didn't see her
also she said she sent um and i have
received it in my personal email
um something from her uh to the whole
count to hold
committee so i'm just asking that the
committee be aware of that
um and look in your email from something
from representative suzanne smith
pertaining to the bill that
representative gordon just
um spoke to us about what bill was that
the one about the grafton county
commissioners thank you representative
i think
system that we have now for signing on
to bills if you can't sign on
to speak once the hearing has started
and what is in the
remote testify with the feet that we get
for people
it might just be a quirk of the system
but it is something we should be aware
of
because emergencies are going to be
happening and people are going to have
to
sign in late um upon occasion so
if i could um representative board of
representative majori i'm more than
happy to answer this question
thank you christine that would be great
uh
so we have to print the testimony sheets
first thing in the morning but it is
understood that
if people sign up after eight o'clock
that it is uh the purview of the chair
to ask for um public
that may have not been signed up in time
for that eight o'clock printing
so there will be public that are not on
the list but we just can't
we aren't able to do it for each bill so
um we just request that the chair ask
for public commentary
and those folks would raise their hands
to be able to speak
well that may that makes sense
i'm not sure how then we have someone
who would be introducing a bill in
someone's
place how does that work the same way
i would recommend that they email the
committee
with that particular change and if it um
they or they raise their hand um we're
in kind of a new world so that's
something i can bring back
i can bring back to um house committee
services with that point and we can
see what we can come up with
hello okay i got it
yep can you hear me a little bit better
now yep
the host muted me oh my goodness
the host doesn't like me
we can hear you um without muting and
i'm that that would be i want to avoid
feedback sorry
i'm just going to say i i accept the
failure on that one because i see that
the email came through
about a quarter after 11 but i didn't
immediately recognize it as someone who
who wanted to stop who wanted to speak
uh to this um it's just that like you
say the system of trying to figure out
if you can
read the email and recognize these folks
um while you're doing the meeting too so
i will be more attentive tonight
and certainly send apologies to
representative smith
representative maggiore yes
how how long is the break do we know
um i imagine it's going to end very soon
okay thank you
okay
so
okay the next build we're going to hear
for the municipal and county committee
is bill house bill 383 relative
to the quarterly a semi-annual
collection of taxes in certain
municipalities
we have
we have carolyn leer from dra to testify
mr chair do you want me to introduce the
bill
uh yes please thank you
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for the record i'm marjorie
porter and i represent hillsborough
district one
the towns of antrim hillsborough in
windsor and um
this bill that we've brought forth is a
bookkeeping bill
that has been uh requested by dra
we had this bill last year and it did
pass this committee
but died in the pandemic and so i'm
going to turn over
for questions and information to carol
and lear who is from
dra who will explain the intricacies of
the bill
thank you
good morning mr chair members of the
committee my name is carolyn lear i'm
the assistant commissioner at the
new hampshire department of revenue can
you all hear me okay yes you're doing
fine
okay um so
this bill really has its roots in a
situation that
occurred in 2017 in the town of
goffstown
the school district had discovered an
accumulated fund balance of
approximately 10 million dollars
and decided to use this money to offset
the amount of taxes that needed to be
raised for local education in
2018. as a result this caused
a significant one-time drop in
goffstown's
property tax rate and
because municipalities use
the prior year's tax rate for purposes
of calculating the first
property tax billing
had the rate not been modified
goffstown would have drastically over
collected
with their first billing and had to
collect significantly less in their
second billing
goffstown reached out to the department
and asked us to assist them with the
situation by
recalculating their tax rate um
for purposes of that first billing to
really account for the fact
that they had a bunch of additional
money that wasn't really accounted for
in last year's rate the effect was to
sort of smooth
out the property tax billing over the
course of that
year and avoid um significantly over
collecting in the first
half we did do
that recalculation perk offs town
request
but we felt that it would be ideal if
the statute was
clear for every municipality um
that this was something that could be
done
and also we think that the legislature
is the right body to sort of weigh
in on how significant
a change in the amount to be collected
needs to be
in order to trigger our ability to do
that recalculation
the legislation sets that um
that at 15 a 15 change from year to year
um that sort of summarizes why we've
requested this bill and i'm happy to
answer any of the committee's questions
thank you for your testimony do you have
any of that in writing that you could
submit to the committee
mr chair i sent you an email on friday
with that
and i can resend it to the full
committee if that's how you'd prefer it
to be disseminated
can you please just send it to the
entire committee
perfect that way the clerk will get it
and
put it as part of the folder for the for
the bill
and we haven't yes we have one question
from representative power
thank you mr chairman um for taking my
question
and thank you ms lear for your testimony
my question is with regard to the
language of this bill
does this pertain only in the instance
or case in which there is
excess tax or excess revenue
no it does not it would it would apply
in the opposite situation as well and in
fact
in the case of the town of goffstown we
did do the recalculation a second
time in the next year because
in 2019 there wasn't a 10 million dollar
excess in revenue in 18 there had been
so we again had to modify the first
property bill
property tax rate for bills upwards
to avoid drastically under collecting
in the first billing for the town of
goffstown
again the goal being just to smooth it
out so that there's only 50
collected in each half of the year
any follow-up yes yes follow-up so
um i was having a little bit of the
difficulty abstracting in my mind
what the what this would look like um i
guess
yeah what it would look like so i guess
my question now is
um is there any
possibility that there could be a
deficit
in the amount of um taxes collected
as opposed to what was raised and
appropriated by the meeting
i think that the answer is no based on
your
most recent explanation is that a
correct understanding
that's that's correct it doesn't change
the ultimate amount of tax that
would be collected in any year it just
um
prevents it from being either over or
under collected in the first half
thank you that clarifies
any other questions from the committee
uh seeing none any any comments or
questions
from the public
mr chair i do have one hand raised from
becky benvenuti of nhma
yes thank you thank you mr chair can you
hear me okay
one time all right and good morning uh
it's almost afternoon members of the
committee for the record my name is
becky benvenuti i am the government
finance advisor for the new hampshire
municipal association and
i wanted to speak today in support of hb
for all the reasons stated by the
sponsor nhma supports this bill
smoothing out the incremental annual tax
billing as ms lear
stated provides a win-win in terms of
cash flow for both municipalities and
individual property taxpayers so we
would encourage
you to vote ought to pass on hb 383
thank you for your time thank you for
your testimony
are there any other comments or
questions for those testifying
yeah seeing none this uh
seems like a pretty clean bill uh and so
i would ask the committee
your thoughts about executing the bill
right now
if unless there are some concerns
and more research needs to be done today
i'll open value
discussion uh tell me if the blue sheet
how many signed up just
there were two people signed up to uh
on the blue sheet uh both were
supporting
but we had an additional we had miss ben
venuti that
additionally testified so you could
count that as three in support
zero opposed zero neutral
thank you it is uh and
so representative porter the question
for you are you uh you introduced the
bill are you uh
okay i'll make a motion about to pass on
hb
383 all right
pretty good
representative dolan would you mind
checking your microphone
i think it's far away from me
how about now can you hear me now much
better thank you
emotion not the past
no we've lost you again
how about now is this better yes
okay so we you know we had a motion
out to pass from representative porter
and a second from representative tripp
is is there any discussion
seeing none i asked the clerk to take
the rule
autocad hb 383 represent pmit
yes representative
did you call me yes uh i'm sorry i
didn't hear
yes thank you
representative clee yes
representative tripp yes representative
guthrie yes
representative lasalle's
yes
representative mcbride yes
representative melvin
representative ayer we ask you to unmute
and vote one more time do we have
trouble hearing you with the audio
yes thank you
uh representative power yes
representative gallagher yes
representative yes
representative george yes
do we
how do you vote yes
thank you uh representative yes
representative yes
college votes yes uh representative
doman yes
19th is george like 31 talent yes
without objection i'll place that in the
consent calendar
thank you i i want to uh
we have one more bill to hear and then
i'm going to make an announcement that
i want to express to the committee
my appreciation for your indulgence is a
little choppy today
changing the format so you can question
witnesses each as they testify
as feedback that was given before
and i've been trying to clean up our
exec calendar by pulling some things in
i'm having a little bit of a medical uh
issue at the
at the moment and uh and i'll
explain that in a minute but what
what i'm going to do before we go to hb
which is going to be our last bill i'm
going to
basically cancel our executive session
this afternoon and
i'm going to make a public announcement
right now
that those bills that remain in our
executive session which are house bill
586 and 445
that we're going to execute them
tomorrow afternoon
and we're going to be postponing those
the executive session on those
three bills and we'll add them to the
calendar
tomorrow afternoon uh we just got
confirmation
with the house clerk that it was uh
appropriate to do it in this way also i
want to
shout out an appreciation to
representative porter
you were absolutely correct in the
interpretation of retaining the bill
that we had spoken about earlier so
thank you for your advice on that
i will get we checked on that as well
and you are correct
uh so we're going to hear one more bill
hb 404 and then we're going to be done
for the day
and tomorrow you should have all the
calendar for tomorrow
and i'll in the meantime i'll get myself
screwed away at the doctor and uh and
we'll continue tomorrow it's it's not a
big deal it's just
okay i've just been informed that you
all should be on distribution now for an
amendment
for out house bill 459
uh which we'll do you will be hearing
that tomorrow that's the uh
that we'll exact that tomorrow with the
other bills that's the
budget that have zero dollars
so in summary we have three
additional bills to exec
tomorrow that we're postponing from this
afternoon to tomorrow at
4 59 586 and 4 45.
any questions about that or is everybody
completely
confused about what i just did
okay um
i did want to mention something because
cody has me uh
383 we had
two in support zero opposed
zero in neutral
next we're going to hear build
[Music]
port which is the preambulation
bill we have a lot of people that have
signed up
to testify that
we have two that support the bill
29 oppose the bill zero in neutral
and we have at least so far eight that
have been asked to testify
those of you who would testify i'm gonna
ask you
to testimony which
which will uh help the clerk uh gather
the folder so that the bill is complete
i'm gonna ask you to hold your comments
to summary comments
uh if we're gonna get through all the
testimony
but we will stop between test testifiers
so that the committee can question you
if they have questions
are there any comments or questions from
the committee
on this bill seeing none
uh see we can start with
um
be happy to introduce the bill so we can
move on okay
very helpful thank you and unless
christina uh
our our researchers see something
different i just do not see
representative harrington i'm stalling
for time obviously
but i do not see representative harry
care
um so please the committee i
am representative representing rocky
camp
northampton rockingham twenty-two
thank you um
let's see
michelle lined up yeah after him
david bigfoot
captain priscilla is all set mr
frizzella
the microphone is yours
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
okay yes you're doing fine
thank you good afternoon mr chairman
thank you for the opportunity to testify
and thank you to the committee
my name is jonathan frisell i live in
colebrook i'm an attorney with offices
in colebrook lancaster in berlin
although i'm an attorney i'm here on my
own i'm not representing any client
i oppose hb 404 i handle court cases
including cases involving real estate
disputes
in some of those cases the judge will
take what we call a view of the
of the property as bound or the boundary
line that's in dispute
the judge and the parties need definite
markers on the ground
as the best evidence of what the borders
are
actual markers are much more helpful and
reliable than photos
or computer images definite markers are
a frame of reference that are not in
dispute
many times that takes the form of a
clearly marked town line
another example of this would be the
white stone markers that dot
places on the edge of the highway
right-of-way
so if i'm in court or preparing a deed
or advising a town board it helps me and
my clients to have those definite
markers
such as a town line that's been blazed
and properly marked
pre-ambulation is a key part of keeping
those town boundaries
as one of the forms of those definite
markers that we need in the legal system
that is why i oppose hb 404 i ask that
it be voted
inexpedient to legislate and i would be
happy to take any questions
any questions from the committee
seeing none we'll move on to mr bigfoot
if he's uh online
mr pickford the microphone's yours
you should be all good well mr bigfoot
that he's there i'm
asking him to hunt you it is
okay i'm sorry um my name is david
bickford i'm from new durham
uh where this bill initiated from the uh
i had asked them to do their
paramulation and point of the laurel to
the slug men
and they avoided it uh year after year
and i finally did
take them to court but i decided to drop
it when
the covid came forward they don't feel
they
have to do it the budget committee said
that they were not interested in doing
the perembulation because they didn't
feel they had to do it
and so there's this feeling out there
that um they don't have to do this even
though the legislature has said for
many many many years that this needs to
be done
now i don't dispute the fact that it may
we may want to make it
uh uh more than seven years
but this bill comes back and says well
whenever the men
feel is a necessity basically that's
like a repeal
when i was a selectman believe me if i
saw that
we wouldn't be doing it okay so if the
legislature wants it done
at all they would they should itl
bill the way it's written okay thank you
thank you very much
thank you any questions from the
committee
from mr bigfoot excuse me
no seeing none
next we have uh
mr grays from the nhma and we have
mr stock after that from new hampshire
timberland association
i just have to heard mr grays
okay all good mr gray's you're up please
uh
thank you mr chair this is nate from the
new hampshire municipal association
we are in support of hp 404
we think that it makes sense to allow
local communities and their governing
boards to determine when it is
appropriate to preambulate
and that's really the summation of my
testimony
thank you thank you for your testimony
yes can i ask you a question to the
question
yes uh yes this is a question from
representative guthrie
mr graves greg if you have any
uh executive uh your testimony do you
have any information as far as
the satellite imagery
as to how effective that is and just
what it is
uh i
i i'm not an expert in the satellite
imagery but
what i would imagine because
realistically what this
premulation is trying to do is
make sure that uh there are clear
boundaries between the towns what you
would be doing with the satellite
imagery
is changing that to gps coordinates
which are obviously regulated by the
the us government and effectively you'd
be able to get
boundary lines that are within inches
um and that that could be very effective
all you would need
obviously to determine the difference
between one town and another is
is a gps device with some
degree of accuracy and i i do know that
many assessors and many
tax mapping organizations for instance
are doing
gps mapping now rather than
doing um you know old
what i would call old-fashioned surveys
of going from
you know the large rock and in the
corner of someone's property to the old
hickory tree as
as is in many deeds i just think that
the
gps based seems to be the most
modern option at the moment
yes can you can you hear me
we start we had a question from
representative tripp
thank you
i have a lot louder from now on
uh is the person from nhmany still there
i am uh so
do i understand that if you wanted to
verify
a point along the line you would use a
gps
device and you would still have to walk
out into the woods or whatever
and the gps device would tell you where
you are
and from that you would be able to say
oh
this is this point is can uh uh
gary and this point is in londonderry
uh i'm not a surveyor so i'm not exactly
sure how they
conduct it but my understanding is they
do do field work where they go out
and they map things on uh via gps and
essentially
they create a 3d model of the earth and
that's what they
they use although it may be smaller to
scale because you're only talking about
someone's property or an individual town
hello presenter fiamonte i i can answer
your question
gps is pretty accurate it used to be uh
where they'd be 15-20 feet away from
the odds but now they're pretty much
right on the money they used to be the
two north or
regular north which is uh
yes follow up i will follow so uh
so what would happen in a boundary
dispute
you you would use these gps coordinates
that are
derived from some method and you would
still have to go out in the woods
and verify that once again
that at this point
everything to the left is in one town
and everything to the right is
that correct
i'd defer to representative pimante
looks like he he knows more about this
than i do
yes last i remember the testimony we had
from last year
and these are markers that are out in
the
field or wherever they have
they get overgrown um after 10 years
you would never find them in gps more
than likely
so the gps will direct you to where the
marker is you have to verify the marker
at that point there right there are
places that are marked
okay does that answer your question
now you're using a uh the gps cord
you want to direct the question to the
person on the
on the line or you want you want to
that's just for this executive all right
i'll be quiet
it's okay you're just gonna kind of
question what he's already said he
doesn't know
okay all right uh
uh representative gallagher had a
question
yes um you have experience
working with satellite imagery yourself
and
if so what has that been
i do not really have any experience with
working with satellite imagery except in
so far i've answered questions about
tax maps and some other legal questions
along that
that edge
and as a follow-up how did
the new hampshire municipal association
come to the determination that satellite
imagery would be a
suitable replacement for perambulation
i think the goal is to try to be as
accurate as possible
for the the town boundaries and to
ensure that people
know where those are um so
it seems like the intent of the statute
is to
have boundary markers um
and the obligation of the select board
to go out and
pre-ambulate with beach just to ensure
that they're there
um you know as it appears that there's a
transition in surveying to gps
use it may make more sense to
[Music]
look at satellite imagery and and gps
use
as as a modern modern approach to this
um again i'm not an expert but
that would seem to be acceptable
and i'm certainly aware that where there
are boundary lines disputes it is up to
the
it could be up to the courts to
determine you know what the exact
boundaries are between
properties whether that's private
properties or municipalities although
hopefully at this point
municipalities are aware of where their
boundaries are given their long-standing
existence
okay any other questions from the
committee
yes this is uh
rachel salas
my question is do other states
use this procedure and
secondly what do you do in the case
of a wetland or a river
or someplace that you physically cannot
traverse
there are no exceptions within the
statute about
whether you can physically traverse or
not um
so i assume that
uh select boards have been required to
pre-emulate those
places have figured out some sort of
option
i would imagine it would be physically
impossible in some cases
but i don't you know i don't know that
those lands are in dispute
so i'm not sure that that many people
are too concerned
as far as other states my understanding
is that there
that massachusetts and other states new
england which originally had this
obligation many of them have
transitioned
to something similar to what the statute
or this
bill would be proposing which is that um
pre-ambulation as
necessary is determined by the local
governing body
so um there wouldn't be
you know an obligation to it at a set
point in time
but i don't believe there are many
states in the union which do require
preambulation
mr chair i um i do recognize that you uh
that you recognize jason stop but i do
see that mr bickford's hand
is raised i don't know if there's a
response to some questions that have
been asked and i
thought i'd bring it to your attention
okay i would ask mr bigfoot
to uh hold on we have a few more people
who like to testify and then we'll come
back
for folks who want to testify a second
time
uh his mark and pardon my uh
attempt at the your last name condo
dammit tracky is that is that close
is that climbing
you see you see mark on the
i do not he's from the new hampshire
land surveyors association okay
we'll come back if he's here uh next
is uh gerald miller and then we'll go to
linda
bronson after that
okay all good hey mr miller
you're out
yes uh can you hear me yes you're
doing fine all right thank you mr
chairman
and members of the committee for letting
me speak to you today
my name is gerald miller i'm a retired
land surveyor currently living in
hampton
and i grew up in france's town i'm
asking you to vote
in expedia to legislate on hb 404
before you today i hope you have been
able to review the two submissions i
sent to this committee dated
february 4th and 5th
that goes into more detail than we can
cover today in this testimony
thank you for your submission i've had
over 40 years
experience as a land surveyor dealing
with town lines
their perambulations limitations
both good and bad the past couple of
decades i've been testifying on a number
of legislative acts that seek to make
rsa 51
ineffective or eliminated completely
once again this proposed act hp
404 four is attempting to essentially
make rsa 51
ineffective by changing sections two
and three this is a really bad idea
the definition of preambulation or to
prambly means to
make an official inspection of the
boundary on foot
this is not something that is optional
it
quote shall be perambulated unquote
if a prerambulation is not done on a
regular timetable
which is currently seven years not
quote as often as the selectmen
determined is necessary
uncle as house bill 404 proposes
then the marks and bounds will
ultimately by either nature
or man-made reasons be lost forever
which has and will result in major
expenses to individuals and
municipalities
also hb 404 proposes adding to rsa
51 colon 2 quote in lieu of
perembulation of the town lines methods
such as satellite imagery may be used
unquote
let's break this down in lieu of
permulation of town lines
means no feet on the ground no eyes on
the bounds
no ability to describe accurately the
status of the town line for section
51 colon 4 the return of rsa 51 that is
to be recorded with the secretary of
state
and in the town records of both towns
such as satellite imagery being used as
an example
of a method that may be used
very broadly very broad terminology and
something that is totally useless as a
substitute
to my knowledge no type of satellite
imagery
whether it be photographic lidar
infrared has the ability to renew
or mark bounds i'm referring to the
second task
listed in rsa 51 colon 2.
in very few cases with the best
government satellite imagery
even be able to see marks or bounds on a
town
line we are talking about a whole host
of monuments of
shapes and material marked field stones
iron stakes
blazed and painted trees piles of stones
concrete and granite posts with carved
dates and initials
a stone in a stone wall on top of a
ridge
a mark on a ledge outcrop just to list a
few
bolts under the a dense cover of trees
and sometimes
covered by fallen leaves or moss
nor would satellite imagery be able to
find missing bounds
that had been dropped from the
perambulation returns due to lack of
proper
permulations or discovered that a
boundary tree
called for had been destroyed due to
logging
or be aware that bounds that have been
dug up
and moved broken or buried by plows
in any number of construction situations
there is nothing in technology as good
as
or in lieu of a proper permutation as
feet on the ground and eyes on the
bounds it's all about carefully
maintaining the bounds
that's what is important about rsa 51
colon 2
and the seven year period intended to
limit the chances of them
being lost and thereby preventing
encumbrances
in courts basically it is human nature
not to do something that you don't want
to do
or don't think you are capable of doing
and you won't unless there is something
that requires you to do by law
it is also human nature to feel guilty
about it too especially when it's your
responsibility
your duty every time there is a change
in members of this committee
another bill like this one is brought
forward for your deliberation
and while i'm alive and made aware of an
attack on this law
i will be there to defend it it's that
important
it is my wish though that i will never
have to do it again
again i respectfully request that you
vote
house bill 404 and expedient to
legislate
thank you thank you uh
mr miller we have mark uh
i believe
i am democracy pronouncing your name
right yes that's correct it's
chondrodematraki
okay you're up thank you very much i'll
make this brief and thank you very much
for for holding the hearing and allowing
us to participate
my name is mark condo demetraki i'm
speaking on behalf of the new hampshire
land surveyors association
and we we are opposed to this bill
we feel that perambulation is a very
important aspect
of determining and maintaining
monumentation
and town boundaries we also believe that
it is an extremely
important historical
uh preservation bill that
as you know new hampshire is one of the
original colonial states
and there are boundary markers that date
back
several hundred years which it is in our
best interest
to preserve i would just like to point
out
several statements that mr gray's
stated about gps and aerial photography
there are multiple
differences in technology out there
there are
multiple vendors that create gps
data collection devices and there are
multiple vendors that
render aerial imagery there is no
standard for the aerial imagery and
aerial imagery
uh can have significant differences due
to
it not being orthorectified correctly um
so you can have overlaps gps
does not collect data very well when you
have areas of heavy and dense
tree cover and so what you end up with
is potential overlaps in that
coordinate data which can then create
more disputes
you can already see uh in different
versions of gis mapping
that communities have that there are
overlaps in
the town lines as they're rendered on
their gis
mapping a lot of this has come from
different coordinate systems and the
discrepancies between the use
of you know state plane or
some other horizontal coordinate
system so the other
the other thing that i just want to
point out is that you know this
law states that the towns must
preambulate
their boundaries to preserve them but it
does not say
that the selectmen themselves have to do
it
the selectmen uh and the town fathers
have the opportunity to get to delegate
this to uh different civic organizations
and there are certainly
many civic organizations that would be
more than willing
you know to perform these tasks on a
regular basis such as the girl scouts
or the boy scouts or other or other
organizations so
it is not something that the selectmen
themselves
are required to do and really i think
until
the legislature creates a specific
standard
that everyone must follow for both
aerial photography
and gps data collection
there is the opportunity for there to be
differences
in that data that is collected and
presented
and then the question will become who is
correct and what information you hold
i'm happy to answer any questions that
the committee has
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
seeing that let me move to oh i'm sorry
mr
representative tripp thank you mr chair
uh i know you're not a lawyer but uh uh
what is the legal definition of a
boundary is it the
marker so i'm i'm
i'm not an attorney so
uh you know a boundary can come in many
many
shapes and forms it can be a natural
monument such as a river
um a ridge of a mountain uh you know
some some other form a lake etc uh it
could be
a stone wall or a stone monument
that was um that was set by
by someone it could be any kind of
iron pipe or rebar
or any myriad of items that could have
been set in the ground
that was determined by the parties to be
that
property corner or or boundary so
monumentation comes in all different
shapes and
sizes
follow up hello please thank you mr
chair so uh
uh since you're not a lawyer would it be
your opinion
that uh the gbs coordinates would be
used to assist
you in finding where the boundaries are
certainly gps coordinates are helpful in
assisting in finding
where those boundaries are if they have
already been established
you know by a specific you know gps
coordinate um you know the issue would
then become that potentially the gps
system
i'm using um may be a little bit
different than
a gps system that someone else is using
which would certainly be different than
a gps that is collected say on someone's
iphone
or samsung phone because again that
would be a different
wave that the device devices is reading
which would give a different
coordinate and a different view so
physically you know physically
preambulating and finding those
monuments
is very important certainly the gps is
going to get you close
but preserving that monumentation
is extremely important and not relying
specifically on that one
aspect of the gps until there is a
specific standard
for that data collection i think would
call into question if a monument was
ever moved or
changed or shifted
where that exact location should be
thank you next we'll hear from
i'm sorry we have a handout from
representatives davis
on mute though
my master to unmute
thank you my apologies um thank you for
taking my question
concerning differences in uh gps systems
i'm i am not
a professional by any stretch of the
imagination but i am
on the planning board here in lebanon
and we use the new hampshire state plane
coordinates
isn't that a statewide system where
everything
agrees with everything else and
therefore there is no
concern that there are differing systems
with differing measurements
in theory yes in theory everything
should be
the same but unfortunately when you're
interjecting
humans into that equation you're always
going to have
some margin of error and it could be
due to the setup of the equipment you
know perhaps someone set equipment up
uh differently or there was an error in
setting up the equipment or there was
different equipment that was used you
know there could be calibration issues
and
measurement devices for setting up that
equipment
so there are always there's always
opportunities to inject error into
information and reading now the wave
itself that comes from the satellite
won't change
but the way that potentially someone
sets the equipment up to
accept that information could may i have
a follow-up question please
yes thank you for that answer and
just to um
i hope you don't consider this flippant
but i'll ask anyway
um when you say injecting
human action into the process
isn't perambulation the most human
action process
that there is and how is it that
physical human perambulation
has none of the faults that the gps
system has
well that's a that's a fantastic
question and
what i want to point out is is the point
of perambulation
is to locate and uncover existing
monumentation and again that's why as
surveyors
we specifically set
and locate specific monumentation
on the ground so that there is no
question that that point where that
monument is
is the delineation of that corner or
line
etc so the permutation of going out
and and finding this monumentation
then obviously would support the use and
collection
of gps but to rely solely
on the aerial photography and the gps
data
and allow these historical monuments to
deteriorate or be lost
would then create other issues and
problems that occur
when once again the data that is
collected is questioned
or there is an issue that's found with
that data
so really the importance of
perambulation is
is maintaining a historical marker of
significance
for the state and its history and
your question certainly has a great
merit and
the the answer lies in the actual
physical
upkeep of these monuments
thank you for that testimony um
next we'll we'll hear from
uh if she's on the line linda bronson
and then tom christensen after that
miss bronson you're up
yes you may need to unmute though
okay i got it now i i couldn't figure
out how to do it because my picture's
not up
can you hear me now you're doing fine
okay
thank thank you chairman dolan and
committee members for allowing me the
time to testify
in regards to house bill 404
i am a resident in wentworth new
hampshire grafton county
along with my husband we manage 200
acres of
mixed hardwoods and conifers our land is
divided nearly 50
50 between the towns of wentworth
and orford interest in this subject
matter stems from management needs to
have these town boundaries clearly
marked and maintained
for this reason i oppose house bill 404
my forest management plan calls for
periodic sustainable harvesting
and the creation of wildlife habitat for
this reason we perform
patch cuts and timber stand improvement
in a somewhat
rotating fashion as all four parcels of
this contiguous property are divided by
the town
line it is imperative that i know
exactly where the line stands
for intent to cut purposes uh
and to assess the timber yield tax
um a couple years ago wentworth and
orford were conducting the perambulation
of the line going through
my property and uh uh
they uh they came to a halt with their
orange paint at the edge of a large
opening
not seeing any more marked trees to
follow because we had
a patch cut there helping them out
we carefully reconstructed the markers
through that cut area
on stumps and rock piles to join the
existing line
enabling future maintenance of the
boundary line
this was possible because of
well-maintained border lines
on both sides of this area
satellite imagery would not have picked
up this
imaginary line
uh on the underground maintenance of the
town boundary lines can also
provide an opportunity for those markers
uh to be on the lookout for possible
current use transgressions for example
as well as just becoming familiar with
changes in the land
my impression in talking with these
fellas is they were
they actually enjoyed the work they
enjoyed meeting the landowners
owners and they uh just enjoyed being
out in the woods
last fall another example last fall my
husband and i decided to build a cabin
for guests
on one of our parcels of land divided by
the two towns
the portion of the forested land
situated in the town of orford
happens to be deed restricted and cannot
be built on
we were easily able to determine the
exact line based on the town markings
to ensure that these restrictions were
not violated
and the cabin was built in the town of
wentworth
recently we placed a conservation
easement on a large segment of our land
and it was critical to know the exact
acreage
and location of the contiguous parcels
per the agreement because it is 85
percent forested satellite images aerial
photos or remote sensing
would not have been able to place these
lines
satellite imagery is a great technology
but it has its limitations
and in the images are only as good as
their resolution
but even high resolution images need to
be validated on the ground
to ensure the trustworthiness of the
interpretation
imaginary lines don't show up on
remotely sensed images
for boundary lines in a forest
especially
ground truthing has to be conducted
these are all examples demonstrating the
importance of perambulating town lines
our state is 82 percent or so forested
forest landowners in the forest product
industry
manage best when sound forest management
plans are in place
accurate and well-marked boundary lines
on the ground
is foundational for the management of
our land
as well as an imperative for settling
boundary disputes
good fences make good neighbors as the
saying goes
towns have an important responsibility
by accurately representing these
boundaries
let them not relinquish this important
responsibility
i oppose house bill 404 and request
that you vote 404 inexpedient to
legislate
thank you so much for your service to
the state and for the opportunity to
testify
i would happily entertain any questions
other questions from the committee yes
representative
thank you mr chair and and thank you for
taking my
question uh miss bronson do i
each time one of these situations has
come
up on your property has somebody
had to go out and
and and identify the boundaries
and has that happen multiple times for
the same boundary
well it's it's usually me who go out
because i know exactly where the
boundaries are and also because our
towns
wentworth and orford do a very good job
of maintaining these boundaries every
seven years
not only do they do it uh with that
frequency but they do it well
you know they use paint that's not gonna
wash off and they don't do it right
after a rain and
and so it's uh it's usually easy to see
thank you
are there any other questions from the
committee
okay next i think our last speaker is
tom christensen is he uh
on the line yes mr christensen the
microphone is us go right ahead
yes that's correct thank you mr chairman
i am speaking in uh opposition to house
bill 404
many of the reasons that have already
been explained by many of you
your guests i'll give you an example
we own a 900 acre tree farm in the town
of limbo
which happens to border the town of
temple and the town of greenfield
and it is on the east
west slope of north pack monadnock
our immediate butter to the west on the
mountain
is a wapak national wildlife refuge
now if you look at a google map
online right today you'll see
that the town boundaries are completely
wrong
okay i don't know where they get the
boundaries from maybe it's gps
some other source but they're wrong
not only are they wrong the usgs is also
wrong
and and the peterborough quadrangle has
been wrong for many years
so what do we have left to rely on
well we have left to rely on surveys on
the ground either a survey
or the monuments that have been
established long ago
by the town fathers where the boundaries
are
so come to find out there's been a mark
stone in the 1800s at one corner between
temple greenfield and limebro one that's
one corner i'm just speaking of our
property
there's over 30 bound boundaries of
straight lines in the town of limebrow
and
the northwest boundary is between
us and greenfield and the and the waupak
national wildlife refuge
so i i would and as a result
we had a survey done which
confirmed that the boundaries which were
set
long ago by the town fathers
and they conducted a
review of all the boundaries on our
property
and a permulation but they appointed a
committee
both greenfield and linebro appointed
the committee
to go out and find out where the heck
these boundaries are i don't know how
long it had been since they
did it the last time but they went out
and sure enough they found the stones
they found the walls they found the
markers so
and that agreed with the survey and so
then everybody knew exactly
where their land was okay it required on
the ground survey if you do if you do a
gps aerial photography
it's all spruce covered you can't tell
what's on the ground
there's no visibility of it so you have
to have either a surveyor or somebody
look work working for the top
ambulating it to identify it on the
ground
and that's that's why i'm opposed to
this bill and i thank you very much for
giving you this opportunity to speak
thank you i would entertain any
questions if you have
thank you very much mr christiansen is
there any questions for this one
i see no questions uh is jason stock
available
i am can you hear me
pray ahead jason okay thank you and
i'll i'll be i'll be brief i i don't
want to
re-plow the ground that you've already
heard um
for the record my name is jason stock
i'm the executive director of the new
hampshire timberland owners association
and
our our members own and manage over a
million acres of timberland
in the state of new hampshire and as
you've heard today
uh you know boundaries and property
lines
and understanding where those boundaries
are on the ground
is is critical it's critical for taxes
it's critical for knowing your the
extent of your property
easements um even rights of ways
so you know again i we are opposed to
to house bill 404 for all the reasons
that you have heard today and
i would be happy to try and answer any
questions
and i appreciate your patience um
for us this is a this is a big and
important
issue it's um perambulation is important
and we we appreciate you taking the time
to hear our testimony and
i'd be happy to try and answer any
questions
thank you thank you jason are there any
questions from the committee for mr
stock
seeing none and the fact of way over
time i think we're going to end the
hearing at this point i know there may
be some people who want to testify a
second time but
i think i think we've got plenty of
testimony on this
hd 404 so i'm going to conclude the
hearing on hb
404 uh the committee
uh you remember i mentioned earlier that
we'll be postponing some of the uh
the last bills for executive session
this afternoon until tomorrow
afternoon so if you had the afternoon
off and i would ask you to be careful
tomorrow with the snow and stay healthy
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you
very much for your indulgence
be well mr speak mr chairman
dave travels back today